hi guys it's time for another episode
and I can't wait to get started so let's
start a time-lapse
Oh
we Sh
please
later
please
well then the gift shop is kind of
finished and I spent way too much time
on it and yeah I'm still trying to look
for something I can put in here like a
sign saying this is a cool gift shop
well basically a cool gift shop name and
I don't really know where I need to get
that stuff but that would be really
awesome though and now I just noticed
that I forgot to add some fences to some
places and I get need to get rid of this
piece in here what this is this is a
very annoying thing basically that
carousel at the entrance
apparently it's huge and it spreads all
over the park and whenever I click
somewhere randomly 9 out of 10 times I
click on the carousel and it really
confuses me as to why that thing is like
300 tiles wide it's like the most big
hitbox have ever seen in this game but
for some reason it does that so I have
to deal with that so that's why that
happens now basically I need to add some
more fences
because I forgot quite a few of them
yeah this is quite a nice one I like
this one really fits the general look of
the park and what I'm looking for ah
there you go again carry so one nope and
now I need - ah yes I need to use that
kind of fence for this place that's kind
of annoying why did I do that to myself
I mean mixing shy guys blends one with
two having to brick walls with a fence
on top of it may look kind of cool but
it's way too much work and I'm a lazy
fatass so I don't want to work oh well
it's not too big this one it's just for
tiles so I can handle that I think
there's a another fan so I forgot
somewhere I think it's in the entrance
of that known sanity ride so I'm going
to have to fix that as well also there
have been lots
well not lots of people but there have
been a few people who have complained
about the ferris wheel and I can see why
they're complaining because if you
haven't seen it yet this is what's
happening
floating staircases all the way so
that's not really something that I want
either so I'm going to have to look for
it fixing that but I don't think that I
can fix it with regular stairs I might
try though I haven't right yet so I can
always try right now let's see where the
hell are the stairs stair hi yeah looks
like I'm going to have to replace them
with this to at least get rid of that
weird floating staircase in the middle
there but now they yeah this is this
isn't good either
damn
oh well it's just merely hitting it
I mean well so many objects in a way I
can't even see a thing well let's just
assume that it's not actually going
through the stairs let's just assume
that it's all perfect and good and that
I can do this now I just need a few more
walls and then I'm basically finished in
here I guess
Ferris wheel was all finished except for
the flower boxes of course I mean maybe
the main planters at the sides that kind
of they've got a few trees but other
than that they're kind of empty so I'm
going to have to fix that later on when
probably even when I'm working off
screen because foliage just creates so
much lag okay so that's the ferris wheel
and now I just need some cue line fences
and I know that I've got a cue line
fence somewhere because I had to get it
for a certain collab but I have no idea
where first of all though let's add some
ballast trades in here I guess I can
yeah it's not too shabby but then I kind
of want a cue fence line think in the
middle here because that makes it looks
like a cue and now you know that I have
a set for it somewhere damn I don't have
a clue as to where oh there it is oh wow
well that was fast
is there also a small curve for this no
quarter quarter thank you
all right so these are some awesome
looking fences oh yeah that's just what
I wanted that's some straight ones does
look like I'm going to have to play some
separates pull things down because now
part of the fence are floating but yeah
that won't be too hard I guess
it should be somewhere in the set or not
of course or I'm just going to leave it
like this you just [ __ ] it anyway yeah
nobody gives a damn about this happening
well how do I fix that let's do it oh
there are the poles
I paid good oops what please oh yeah of
course this happens what the [ __ ] what I
am I'm very much confused what the [ __ ]
is this I damn it
I swear and the real theme park kids are
gonna be walking all up into the fence
die you know what screw it so yeah
that's basically it right now oh I've
really done this spent way too much time
on a one simple gift shop which barely
has any interior decorating right and
wait did I I know other than that it's
pretty much okay I guess I just saw that
I missed one little war but nobody's
going to nobody's going to see that so
yeah that's it for this episode
tune in next time to see me do [ __ ] over
here I guess so yeah
til then